I know these two little girls Peeta and
Sadie their three and a half years old
you know those kids that are so cute you
want to eat them well that's how these
two are now there's studies that say
that you can tell a lot about a child by
watching how they interact in their
natural environment at a very young age
so instead of telling you about PETA and
Sadie I'm gonna tell you how they both
interact with a big brown box huge it's
got a little door on the side now Sadie
walks up to the box very cautiously she
opens the door she steps in and then she
stretches out her arms and tries to
touch both sides which she can't so
she's a little disappointed she walks
around the box and then she stops at one
edge and starts putting one foot in
front of the other in front of the other
almost as if she's counting but she's
brie and a half she can't count now PETA
marches right over to that box she puts
her hands on the outside and she slides
it all around the perimeter she opens
the door she goes inside she lays down
on the floor she looks up at the ceiling
she turns around she starts knocking on
the floor and then she stops she starts
knocking again but this time listening
intently almost as if she's trying to
figure out if this is a sound she's ever
heard before now I have a question to
post you which one is this Martin if
you're having trouble answering this
question I still have a harder one for
you which one deserves a happy
fulfilling life if you couldn't answer
the first question then you're
definitely struggling with this one so
why am I asking it because every day
whether you think about it or not this
kind of harvesting is happening in our
schools in schools and
we reward what is typically thought of
as left brain intelligence so skills
such as analytics and critical thinking
we don't reward what is typically
associated with right brain dominance
which is far more creative more spatial
thinking now I'm bringing up this
distinction because the story of PETA
and sadie is inspired by the story of
myself and my sister and I have a theory
that the moment at which our paths
diverged determining whether we were
successful or not is tied to one
critical ingredient that is synonymous
with mentoring now if you perform well
in school perform well academically you
not only get lots of opportunities but
you also get this extra thing that I'm
talking about that I'm arguing is the
most important thing to helping a child
succeed it's called hope and I want you
to now think of hope is also being
synonymous with mentoring because that's
exactly what it is there are lots of
sophisticated definitions for mentoring
but at its basic level mentoring is
about helping a child understand but
their life has value giving a child hope
so I got one formula for you first
formula is hope equals mentoring second
one high IQ equals success that one's
pretty obvious you do well in school
you're more likely to get accolades and
achieve what's considered financial and
professional success now here's a third
one hi eq equals success emotional
quotient
it's defined as the ability to recognize
and regulate our own emotions and that
of others its associated with
self-regulation self-awareness and
motivation or drive and now if you think
about it IQ doesn't control those things
you can be very smart naturally and
still have no motivation or you could be
struggling through math and sciences but
you have that drive so you're going to
make it and eventually you do succeed
now here's where mentoring comes in eq
can be developed and the stats show that
the easiest way to develop that in
children is through mentoring now if you
are a child that naturally does well in
school then the system is designed to
already nurture your inclination towards
developing you think about it you do
well in school you get a lot of positive
affirmation you're told that you're
smart and that motivates you to do
better in school and then you get
opportunities and then that opens up
whole new world to you and that
motivates do to do better at success now
let's say little pita is also highly
intelligent but she's got that right
brain intelligence bummer
and she also has low EQ how she gonna
develop it how's that story has that
story look she's struggling in school no
one's telling her she's smart no one's
telling her that she is this bright
future that's just within her reach now
I mentioned before that the story of
PETA and sadie is very much the story of
my sister and I and I'm now going to
tell you a little bit more about my
sister so you can understand and
visualize kind of how that story with
PETA ends up developing so my sister and
I are Irish twins exactly you're apart
same parents same environment same
everything up until a certain point but
different talents my sister is a
creative genius she's also a human gps
navigator she thinks in shapes and
diagrams whereas i always need
instructions but she didn't excel a
school and what happened to her is
similar to what happens to a lot of kids
that I've encountered in over 20 years
of mentoring she started to make bad
choices she lost hope and then bad
choices led to bad consequences and then
matlin led to worse choices and then
that led to worse consequences now
anyone looking at this story from the
outside would have written her off as
hopeless but along came a mentor
who gave her hope and I literally
witnessed her life do a complete 180 so
my passion for mentoring it didn't just
start with well it did it partly started
with this early sense of injustice
related to education but it also
continues and persists because of the
example of my story of my sister now
what I want to leave you with today is
one hopefully you're now looking at
you're looking at poor performance as
far too nuanced to be explained by
laziness or a no interest on the part of
a student no desire to learn it's more
complicated than that too I hope that
you have this new association between
hope and mentoring and finally if you've
never mentored before or maybe you
haven't mentored in a while then I'm
hoping that just a little bit you're
considering adding this the long list of
things that you hope to do when you
leave Stamford and make a huge impact on
the world thank you
you